And here's the issue for his attorney. As his attorney, he can't
tell Destiny to go delete documents. But you also can't tell
your client, hey, retain child on your computer. No. What his
attorney should be telling him is you need to contemplate the
the criminal ramifications of this and govern yourself accordingly.
Which means you should delete that right now because here's the
deal. You can't give that to Pixie. Like if there's if there's
a discovery demand and he has to turn that over. You can't give
that to Pixie. Pixie can't hold on to it. Like I said, Pixie
her attorneys. No, you like child's like Chernobyl graphite.
You guys, you can't touch it. You can't touch it. >> Gather
your evidence. Submit it to the state attorneys. >> I think
uh Sean might call in here. Give me a second. Hey, how's it going?
>> I'm doing good. How are you? >> Uh doing quite
well. Welcome to the stream, guys. This is uh Sean, potentially
criminal.
Uh I think also known as some people refer to you as the Kiwi
Farms lawyer, right? Guy who posts on KF who's also a lawyer.
>> Yes. Yes, I'm Yes, I do. >> I I don't necessarily
think that makes you evil. Uh I think a lot of people see it
that way. I I just think it's like a it's a message board. I
understand that you use it. Um and it it doesn't really mean
anything, right? You're not on there committing crimes. You're
not on there harassing people. You're just on there giving your
legal opinion from what I've seen. just taking fun. Oh, yeah.
No, no, I agree. Um, I just think this is funny though. Connor's
on this uh I started looking into this. I thought it was on his
normal channel, but this is a network about Valor and veterans
and he's talking about his friend the nons. It's like, buddy,
like
what what is what is this the appropriate forum for this on your
this channel here? I mean, come on now. >> So, positive
masculinity, it's like I think meant to be like an antidote to
the red pill kind of thing, right?
>> Yeah, it is. But it's like, yeah, this is this is this
is the masculine thing to do.
>> Doesn't seem to be. >> Yeah. The real Chad just
gets the pictures. I I mean, here here's Connor. Like, I get
it. Conor's like, "Well, if there's something wrong, go to the
prosecutor." Okay, great. A lot of illegal does not get prosecuted.
So, this is still really illegal. It's still absolutely disgusting.
I mean, could he not get prosecuted? Sure. He's a law cow.
Law cows like Destiny have this innate ability to avoid responsibility.
It's a very common trait they all have. So, I don't know what's
going to happen to him. >> Yeah. I think um I would be
shocked if he avoids any criminal scrutiny for this because uh
obviously it's it's got like such a massive public like I don't
know there's so much PR around it. I don't understand how is
like um like the local police department. You don't at least
look into this and prosecute it, right? Well, I mean, like I
said, I think the bigger cell, if you really wanted to pitch
it, is go to Pam Bondi's office and say, "Look, we got this,
you know, the biggest left-wing, you know, political streamer
out there has got, you know, got CP on his computer and like
you could take him down and it'll be the biggest dub for you
and Trump." If I was Destiny, I'd be terrified because that would
be very politically
>> and I could see it happening. If you really wanted to
be, okay, if you really were super [__] up, okay,
>> you could go to you could try to go through the uh what
the family of that firefighter who got shot, show them the clips
of Destiny laughing about that guy getting saying he doesn't
care about that guy getting shot. Say, "Hey, don't you guys have
a line to Trump? >> Isn't this really up? Did you know
this guy got caught with like CP on his >> That would be
an interesting way of doing it. But like I said, I mean, people
like this get noticed and there's, you know, Trump's got staffers
and Pam Bonnie's got staffers and if they can see an easy slam
dunk, look, we can go, you know, do what they're decapitating
what they think the online left is and uh, you know, scoring
some points at the same time. I could definitely see it.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think they're constantly I if I've learned
anything about Trump, it's that you can always engage in a little
culture war, right? Like it's always a good time, especially
with the Epstein things. It just could be a way for them to regain
some positive PR on that topic, right? >> Persecuting like
or prosecuting actual child criminals. >> Oh, I think so.
And I'm very disappointed with how they handled it. But yeah,
this is this is something there where it's like this is this
is one that nobody's going to be able to say, "Oh, poor, you
know, people are crying about John Bolt. Nobody's going to be
crying for Destiny." >> No. No. And that's the other thing
is I think um you talked about how this is going to hurt him
in Pixie civil case, right? That like he might actually fail
to produce documents for discovery now, >> He has Well,
yeah. Because he can't give them over.
And Pixie could say, "Your honor, he's not giving us everything.
We know he has we know he has other stuff." And then Destiny
is going to have to say, "You're right. I can't." Because he
can't he can't say, "Nuhuh, judge. Look, it's because normally
you have to have a privilege or you have to say it's outside
the scope of discovery and saying it has nothing to do with Pixie
like okay well what's it all about that that's the problem for
Destiny because if they have to admit to what it is that that's
the problem. Uh yeah, because I mean you don't want to you defin
I call me crazy. I feel like there's no way you want to go to
trial
uh with those kinds of allegations hanging over you, right? Like
I don't know
that seems rough, right? Well, going to trial, yes, but just
getting into discovery cuz at some point this is going to have
to come out and Des
is worried about his case of Pixie. It's like, dude, you're you
you have to avoid the criminal liability now. That's your primary
goal, >> man. And yeah, like I I don't know how he could
possibly go, you know, even if he believed there's a 99% chance
she's overage, isn't the 1% chance of like having felonies that
like carry up to five or 15 years in prison? I feel like that
1% chance you got to avoid that, right? I I don't know how this
calculus was 99 to1. I think that's a little different, but we
know it's not 99 to1. >> Well, no, it's Sorry. I'm saying
when he's told by by Solo in November that like she's a minor,
I I think even if he was like, "I'm positive you're lying." I
think there's got to be like a 1 to 5% chance you think he could
be telling the truth. And based on that, you probably got to
go turn that over to the cops at that point. That seems I kind
of open and shut to me, right? >> Oh, yeah. Yeah. And and
that's the thing. And the funny part is under federal law, if
you immediately notify the police and you turn it over, you actually
have some affirmative defenses.
Uh but one of those affirm those affirmed defenses go out the
window when you distribute it >> or hold on to it for an
excessive amount of time. So he's got a lot of problems. >> Yeah.
And that's the uh that's the
>> big thing, man. Oh, sorry. Just real quick. That's like
the big thing to me is he's got that two-month period where the
the stuff leaks, right? And Solo tells him, okay, in November
tells him, hey, just so you know, she's underage. And he's got
a two-month period before he's g served a notice to retain evidence
or uh what is it? Um like to preserve evidence before he gives
that notice. He's got two months. Yeah. Before the notice to
preserve documents
and he held it that entire time. >> That seems to blow
out of the water any affirmative defense with regards to like,
oh, I didn't know. In my opinion. >> Oh, I think so. I
think so. And yeah, if if if you got told, hey, this person's
underage, yes, immediately your first thought should be deleted.
Get rid of it. Like the moment you know that it's an issue.
Well, hold on. Do you if do you delete it or do you I feel like
So maybe you know more about this. I feel like you have to go
to the authorities at that point, right? To transfer it to them.
>> Well, you go to the authorities and you say, "Look,
this immediately happened. It came to me. These people sent it
to me. Here's my Discord logs. Here's all the information they
gave." Like through his attorneys, you go do all this, but here's
my Discord logs. Here's everything I did. And I deleted it off
my hard drive. So, you can say, "Look, here's all the information.
You can get it. get your subpoenas from Discord,
but to have it kicking around at all is not a good idea. It needs
to be you got to get rid of it. >> Yeah, I I think that's
got to be your number one priority is how do I get rid of it
and how do I do that without, you know, totally destroying evidence.
So whether that's talking to a lawyer calling I know I I believe
Discord's also a thing you could do. So because he received it
on Discord, he should be able to go to Discord and say, "Hey,
I'm reporting this to you. Like this is child. I'm deleting it.
You have to retain it, right? >> I'm getting off of my
You can retain it." He didn't tell anybody. If he thought there
was any.
And the problem for Destiny is though, he plays so fast and loose
with this. Like he's talking about the age play and all that
other stuff. It's like nobody's nobody's going to believe him.
I'm going to come and abduct you. I think he's at some point
he talks about going to Chicago or somewhere somewhere in like
uh not Chicago. I think he's flying to Chicago, but it's somewhere
in like uh in the Midwest, we'll say. Okay. It's not Chicago
actually, but somewhere in the Midwest, he talks about flying
there and he says, "If I have a layover, if my flight gets canceled,
I'm coming to abduct you." It's like, >> "Yeah." Yeah.
And that's >> Yeah. And um it's it that's bad. And the
one thing you kind of mentioned with the group chat, if he had
taken out all the parts that were in nature, so he's just like
having them try to like I think like he was trying to just like
basically
look this up and figure out where she is and who she is. that
might be okay as long as it's not portraying anything. So, kind
of like what he said to Willie Mack where it's like just the
top part of a picture. If there's nothing in the picture that's
you're like, "Okay, that's >> yeah, technically it's not
breaking the law, but still you don't need any
>> you don't need anything affiliated with CP on your computer
or in a message with anybody you have." So, I think >> Oh,
go. >> No, it's just it's just a bad idea. It's just a
bad idea.
>> Yeah. And I think the >> point it looks like,
well, how do we know you didn't have any more? >> Well,
and I think there is I I think there's indications that he got
quite a bit from this girl, right? Like I think in some of the
Florida statutes it says
I think intent to to transmit or intent
it's like show off or something. I can't remember what the verb
is exactly, right? But I think it says
holding five or more images and then there's another part of
the statute that says 10 or more images. And you said something
like I think when I watched your Kino Casino appearance, I think
you said something like they can possibly count the frames of
the video as 10 images some cases. Oh, no, no, no. Like you can
you can count each frame as an image. So like if it's a it's
a minute long video, that's a lot of frames. >> That's
that doesn't sound great. I >> I've only seen I've only
I've only I I've know of attorneys where the tap they've tapping
their client. I haven't had to deal with that. I've just normally
they got caught with a video and that's they just charge them
for a >> Yeah. Yeah. Oh, there was one more thing here.
Oh, um, so we have I don't know if you're too familiar with all
of the like super like the particulars, but there was something
leaked that was a set of Twitter messages that we can't verify
and then an email explaining this group chat that can't be like
verified, but seems to have had pieces of it verified. And in
that email, they do say that they had to remind Destiny to actually
censor like genitalia in some of the screen caps he was giving
because he was sending like because there was some concern that
she was under 18. >> Mhm. Yeah. Yeah. No, that's the thing.
Like basically, yeah, with that group chat where they were trying
to hunt Rose down and figure out who she was, it's >> So
I Yeah. I don't know if that's >> if that's the case. I
feel like that's I I don't know. I hate to say that it seems
like it should be open and shut at that point, but it seems like
it should be open and shut. >> I I mean, yeah, that that
that if you're not doing any like it just there's so many ways
for Destiny, the things he's done and the things he said that
every one of these things he's done, it makes him look bad and
it only makes him look worse and worse and worse and worse and
>> Oh boy. Um, >> somebody in chat saying, um, can
you ask him saying his lawyers told him to keep it? No, his lawyer
would never tell. No lawyer in the world is going to tell you,
hey, keep this stuff that's literally radioactive.
Like there's there's no you can't. Now >> I notic you use
the same metaphor I did with the Chernobyl reactor, the graphite.
I was saying it's like radioactive and you need somebody who
can go touch it, right? >> No. No. Nobody can touch it.
Nobody can touch it. Nobody's allowed to touch it. The only people
>> government investigators,
>> they're the only ones. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> His
lawyers can't touch it. Nobody else can touch it. I can't tell
you as an attorney to delete evidence in response to a pending
civil matter. I can't tell you to destroy evidence in a potential
criminal case where you know or likely know you might be under
investigation
um and you get charged with tampering obstructing justice but
I can say you know you need to figure out how what you could
do to minimize your criminal liability right now. Hint hint and
that means trying to get rid of stuff which I think I think that
like basically his statements when you add up his statements
on this front that like clearly his lawyer couldn't have told
him that. It seems obvious to me that his lawyer told him to
retain the stuff from that conversation without the understanding
at all
was potentially below 18, right?
>> His lawyer has no idea. >> Yeah, pretty obvious
to me.
>> Oh boy. I'm trying to think of any other questions.
I think I sent you most of my relevant questions in the DMs,
but I'll just I'll review those really quickly um just to make
sure I've asked most of them on here. >> I mean, he does
have some advantages. He lives in Miami, so yeah, the Miami Dade
prosecutor might be like, "I got bigger problems to worry about."
Um, had he done it out here in Ohio where I live. Oh, buddy.
And even in, you know, downtown Cleveland, they would find a
way to string him up for this. Yeah, I would imagine. I think
um
I think so long as there's a like sufficient media circus around
it, I I do believe that they will look at it, but again, it's
um it'll all depend on like how much more this catches on. I'm
surprised. No, this happened the first time. A lot of conservative
influencers didn't really start talking about this and it's it
seems to be happening again where there aren't a lot of conservative
like you'd think Ben Shapiro Tim Pool hate this guy, right? I
would have thought that they'd be like bring this stuff up. It
seems like they totally avoided. I >> I think they want
a little more
>> Yeah, that's fair. Yeah, there's a it's difficult for
people to like evaluate the evidence. Like the evidence, if you
do evaluate it, seems basically slam dunk. Like you would have
to have a crazy conspiracy to make to to fabricate the evidence
like as it's been laid out, right? to show that she's uh the
girl was 17. But I understand how most people aren't going to
take the time to evaluate that and it can seem like a sketchy
source to some people. >> Yeah. And and to be fair, if
you're Ben Shapiro, he's going to have to explain who you are,
who Queman is, who Rose and Blav and Cherry, and you know, like
that that's way too much lore for Prime Time
>> Yeah, I could see that. >> And that that that's
just a thing. That's just a thing there. Um No. And uh somebody
in your chat said, "Could he just give it to his lawyer on a
hard drive?" No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. >> His
lawyer is also not even in the state, right? Like Brett is not
somebody who lives in Florida. >> But it it doesn't matter
if Brenler had an office in Florida. You can't put it on a hard
drive and give it to him. No, cuz now he's accepting child. No,
you can't accept it. I It doesn't matter that if it's encrypted
and there is no way for the attorney to open it up. No, cuz you
still know you're possessing encrypted child. No, you cannot
hold on to it. >> Okay. Um, can you tell us anything about
the like sentencing guidelines in Florida? Like what what somebody
would be looking at for stuff like this? >> Like in some
of the scenarios you think have like been kind of proven out
to some extent. >> Well, federally, I mean, you're looking
at like possibly like 5 to 15 years each count. 5 to 20 years
depending on what's gone on there. And if we could confirm that
Rose is under the age of 18 and when all this happened when he
said like I want to fly you down,
you know, and you've been treating dudes with this minor, you're
now guilty of enticing a minor to come across state lines for
purposes of activity. So like R. Kelly level things are could
start happening to him. Um there's a lot a lot of things that
could start stacking up fast. Oh, that would be crazy with the
with enticing a minor over state lines with a like to I think
it's with intent to send traffic or something like that, right?
Or with purposes. So with that, does that require knowledge?
Do you know at a federal level? >> No. Age is not a mistake
of age is not a defense like you know and at at some point the
age play like part it's a strict liability offense. And the idea
is if you're [__] around like this, you should know
like it the you are the adult. You're 35 years old. you're a
grown ass man.
You know, that's the risk you take when you play around with
jailbait.
Like, it's it's a thing because we don't force the 17-year-old
to, you know, we don't let kids get credit cards cuz they're
not they're not
>> So, then running around, no, that's on >> Well,
and the issue is like it's so hard to prove intent and what people
know that like you give so much cover to this kind of crime if
you give like the the know like they have to knowingly commit
it, right? And that's that's why it happened. I don't know. I
didn't know. Oops. Sorry.
>> And and basically like almost anybody could claim that,
right? In basically every situation you get these really long
drawn up court cases. So it just seems easier to me. That seems
to be the entire purpose of strict liability or um like statutory
crimes. It's just like, hey, we we're not going to bother with
this. Don't [__] around with kids that are close.
That's all you need to know, you know? >> Yeah. But but
for Florida, like a second degree felony is like a 15-year term.
A third degree is like five. And there's all kinds of things
they can do in between or things they might be able to ratchet
up or down on him for. So Destiny needs to he is not in a good
spot, man. Maybe nothing happens, but he's going to have to sit,
you know, statute of limitations that could always be creeping
over his shoulder.
So, you know, that that will wear a hole in your head having
to think about that. Uh the other thing would be
I believe that he's cleared like all of the evidence with um
one one thing that works against him as well is I think he's
cleared a lot of the evidence. It's so strange that he said he
retained these things right to Willie Mack because
like technically if he deleted on the Discord end I I would think
you'd be hoping that Discord wouldn't retain copies and eventually
like there just wouldn't be any evidence of this actually happening,
right? You could kind of >> Well, Discord retains copies
because they have to and like everything that gets sent. So if
they didn't, they would have a lot of problems under the law
that this happening. But Discord has the like they have the obligation
to as soon as they know about it immediately go tell the police.
>> Yes. But I don't know if it's even been reported to
Discord explicitly as an instance of CSAM. I don't know that
he's done that. And so Discord's normal data retention policy
is 30 days, right? So I don't know if those Solo or Rose Discord
accounts exist. And if they've been deleted for up to 30 days,
it's possible some of this stuff was getting cleared out of like
Discord servers. It it could theoretically, but remember Destin
all these exist, so somebody has it all.
Yeah, I think I think it's crazy that he he felt like Willie
Mack
was he thought Willie Mack would have no problem with this, right?
That gives you like an idea of what he thought about this guy.
He thought, I can tell him about all this and he's not going
to have any issues, which is I can't think of anybody I, you
know, can you think of somebody you tell that you like murdered
someone to and like somebody you don't have like a close personal
friendship with, you just tell them, "Hey, I murdered this guy
and expect them not to say anything." >> I mean, it's crazy.
>> What's on what's on your screen right
>> Uh, Minecraft jumping or what are you talking about?
>> Well, I'm sorry. I had to pause where Connor was on,
but it's like why why do you think he would tell people? Because
like look at look what happens. not not just a simple oh my god
this is awful and disgusting he had to break down this chart
and like you know Microsoft paint charts with like going through
stuff why not just say it's really awful if you did it you deserve
to get put on a wall and whatever happens to you happens to you
but like think about all the people in Destiny's orbit and all
the people dealing with him and won't just come out and say oh
my god this is awful and all the things he's gotten away with
in the past so why would you not think you're still okay >> I
think that's where a lot of his audience is at right is they've
seen him get accused of some really bad things in the past and
they follow that same line of logic. Yeah. That like this guy
this guy always comes out on top. This guy always skates in the
end. Like why would we why would we abandon Chip now? It's >> Yeah.
No, I mean like that's part of it. But yeah, it's just >> you
know this is how these people
That's the that's
>> you know how long have they known all this other nasty
crap has been going on for years and years now and they're just
like oh that's just Stephen. He's on America. Dude, that's that's
maybe the worst part of this entire thing when so many people
have used the excuse like, "Guys, Trump's in the White House.
Like, we need to fight against fascism and destiny is our best
tool." It's like, "What are we going to allow? What where do
you where do you draw the line? What do you allow from this guy
if he's the best to fight against fascism?" Like, I don't know
how you can believe that, right? He is an anchor to your movement
at this point. He has been an anchor to your movement for a long
time. Yes. But all these people will say, "No, no, no. He's he's
so important." >> I agree. But as somebody on the right,
I just sit here and laugh. I think it's hilar total orbit or
death. >> Damn.
Her orbiter, right? I got out of there when I learned about some
of this >> No, no, I'm just like, you know, like guys and
like chat, a lot of you guys out of there, but like the entire
orbit is just disintegrating and you know, like I'm here to watch
it. >> Yeah. I mean, I'm man, I try to I try to maintain
some level of like distance or, you know, how do I how do I put
this?
Like um professionalism, but yeah, I just I I can't help but
when I watch that Willy Mack video come out, laugh. Okay. What
did you think of the call to the cops by the way? Like um and
specifically that we know the logs came out on the 20th. The
video gets posted on the 20th or 21st with the call the cops.
I don't understand like wouldn't you want to let him let the
cops do some work there or I I mean I it's okay. I mean like
they're going to do what they're going to do and you know it's
not like Destiny's going to be able to get rid of everything.
Like he's not probably smart enough to delete everything. And
even if he did, there's enough stuff out there. Like I, you know,
I I applaud Willie Mack for doing it. I think it was very like
my it got my anxiety up listening to this guy talk to the police,
but um you know, he he did what he did the right thing. Like
I can't, you know, fault him for that. It's just he probably
should have had somebody help him out. Like as much as I hate
to say like, you know, you're like, "Oh, he's telling people
get an attorney because they want attorneys to make money." No,
that's just you're going to tell the police, "Hey, Mr. police
man. My friend was talking to me about and wanted to share like,
you know, his CP collection with me and then the cops would be
like, "Well, wait, why is he he's your friend?" And like like
you see what I mean? Like they might think >> why did he
feel comfortable telling you that? Exactly. >> Yeah. Yeah.
And that that's just where it's like that could easily you know
what I doubt and Willie M could be fine, but in the meantime
the cops come by your house, kick in your door, they take all
your devices and guess what people think when that happens?
>> Uh the worst probably. >> Yeah. They like the
news will come out. Yeah. This man, this gentleman lost all his
electronic devices and then even if you get cleared >> in
connection with this case in Miami,
>> Look at all these videos he's done uh talking about
this guy in the past. >> Oh boy. >> But but I applaud
him for doing the right thing. I mean that that was Yeah, that
was that was a hard thing to do and you could tell and you could
see it on his face when he's talking, but he did the right thing.
Uh yeah, I me personally I think he uh I think he was uh kind
of making some alliances with Destiny. They were thinking some
things weren't quite so bad. >> I have a lot of good tensions
with Willie Mack, by the way, just so you >> I understand
that and I and I know and yeah, there's a like, you know, who
was grifting what, how were they doing it, and I I get that.
But at the end of the day, man, he found his, you know, destiny
came to the took him to the Rubicon and he's like, "Yeah, I don't
want to cross this river. >> I'm not good. I'm not good
with this.
Um
I do believe there are a couple of states where you're legally
mandated to report it as well, right? Like if you >> not
not as a uh any mandatory reporting is generally for like teachers
or certain professions, the the the the idea as a general citizen,
you have to report a crime. Uh we don't do that because that's,
you know, it's not your job.
Well, I I thought so, but I thought there was a li a law. Uh
I I can talk to you about it after because I I would have to
put a location out there for him and I don't want to do that.
That wouldn't be appropriate on my stream. So, but I I thought
there was a law, but maybe not. Maybe not. Maybe I'm misinterpreting.
Yeah, I'd heard four states do they have a law that explicitly
makes it like a requirement to report specifically instances
of child sex abuse, right?
>> Like I said, I could without seeing that state's law
at the top of my head. I mean, they may pass that, but I would
argue that's still
Yeah. Sure. Sure. >> The average citizen to be forced to
undertake activity. Now, like I'm an attorney, so if I'm a guardian
and light on a case and I find out the kids are getting abused,
I have to report that. Social workers have to report it. Doctors
and teachers. But to make the average person be involved in those
things, I don't support that idea. I hope people would do what
they think is right, but I don't want the government to be forcing
that. Like, we used to do that back in the day. It was called
miss prison of a felony if you didn't report things. But I don't
think that's the government should not be going after people
like that.
>> I see. I see what you're saying that like you you believe
federally like that would be not federally in any state. It would
be non-constitutional.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. If you if you see your neighbor
sitting there, you know, loading up sacks of sensitized fertilizer
and he's got a map of Time Square up on the wall and you know,
like it's easy to put two and two together. If you don't report
that, I mean, I hope you would, but if you don't, like, you should
not be held responsible for that.
>> Okay. Uh, I thought it was really interesting that uh
it seems when I looked into it that, you know, his attorneys
actually might not be required to report that. >> Like
I think they would have advised him obviously to uh handle it
appropriately. >> That violates violates rule 1.6 of confidentiality.
I don't have to I only have to report if you're committing a
fraud on the court, but I just have to say, your honor, something's
not right. Like if you told me tomorrow, hey, I've got, you know,
I'm representing a domestic violence. You're like, I'm going
to go kill my ex-wife tomorrow. I don't have to tell anybody
about that.
I can, but I don't have to.
Okay.
Yeah. I thought I thought like basically so the possession is
a crime. The possession itself is a crime. And I thought if you
had knowledge of an actual crime taking place uh with regards
to like child abuse that you have to report that. I thought that
was a thing. And I I looked it up. It seems like, you know, as
long as they there's like some rule, but it's basically like
if he's just if if there was like expression of like I'm going
to go abuse this child, then they would have to report it in
some way. I think there's a line in Florida in the Florida bar.
Like I think it's a bar rule that says that. But um or it might
be the American Bar Association actually, but I don't know. >> Remember
the American Bar Association's not binding on anybody. Um >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, but that would that would still affect your what?
Like uh I I assume like character and fitness reviews and stuff
for different bar associations, right? >> Well, I mean
if Well, so well I'm just seeing here what Florida's because
it's rule 1.6 is confidentiality.
Um, you know, like I said, the rule is if if somebody's going
to do something, I have the I legally am allowed to go notify
and raise the alarm and I won't be held responsible for that.
So, normally if you violate confidentiality, that's the one of
the death penalty things because >> you also it kind of
hurts you as a lawyer because if you're willing to snitch out
your client, that looks really bad for the brand. Um I Yes. Okay.
I see the difference here. I thought I was thinking mandatory
reporting, but it seems like most of these laws would be geared
towards if you feel um if you feel bound by your conscience to
report something, here are the cases where we won't hold you
responsible for breaking confidentiality. It's more from that
angle, right? >> Yeah. Yeah. I don't have to, but I but
I can if I want to.
>> Okay. Yeah. And I don't think uh I don't know if Andrew
Brenler would feel bound by conscience on anything that these
people could bring him. It seems like he's chosen a clientele
where he's just he's just decided these are his guys. I assume
he gets to charge a top dollar for that, right? >> Yeah.
I mean, well, part of being an attorney is your willingness to
be discreet. And if you're an attorney who's going to run a gossip
column, you're not going to have a lot of >> Yeah. No,
it's totally fair. So, it's not even just Bratler. It's me. I
have clients who have I I know that they've told me they're going
to do all kinds of stuff. I'm pretty sure they've done all kinds
of stuff. I know for a fact they've done all kinds of stuff.
It's like, no, that's that's it's the it's the police's job to
catch them, not >> All right. I I feel like probably the
kid stuff is like the one place where I'd say I I think you would
be compelled. But yeah, I I get the moral >> I mean, at
that point, if I know they're doing something, I would probably
figure out a way to disengage from that representation.
Um, I mean, if if a direct harm was going to happen, like for
example, like I'm going to go up a school tomorrow, I would probably
go tell the police. I'm willing to take that hit at some point
if I know for a fact like undoubtedly like actual children are
being injured at that point. Yeah. I'd be getting involved, but
I don't have to as the big thing. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Like you said, I I misunderstood maybe and thought it was
mandatory reporting or like you but you're saying it's just you
can these are the things that let you pierce confidentiality
on the lawyer side. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah.
That makes a lot more sense. Okay.
Oh man, trying to think of I got you here. I I I've had other
questions about the uh the law and I'm trying to figure out which
ones. Uh what's your opinion on Pixie's case? Have you looked
into the recent motion they filed about Destiny reading that
transcript verbatim on a screen? Yeah, that that that
you you should you're not supposed to do that. You're supposed
to shut up. Um I will say
um based on the way some of the fact like initially Pixie had
a pretty solid case on its face, Destiny as attorney have done
a good job at going after whether you know the time frame of
what Pixie sent to Destiny and when you know Destiny sent that
out that it might not be covered. But then there is this Abby
MC girl. Um, I mean, they might have to dismiss and refile because
>> they might not get their complaint
>> Yeah. And honestly, I will say this much, uh, the way
Pixie's attorneys have handled this, um, procedurally, I've not
been impressed with. Like when they've been worried about just
how they've been going about complaining and whining that Destiny
has deleted or will be deleting things, like they haven't filed
for discovery. They haven't done like they haven't done a lot
that it's kind of like the basic stuff. So, I I don't know what
their game plan is, but I think that they just got a bunch of
wind in their sales with this stuff here. >> Yeah. I mean,
it gives them something to I I've heard some attorneys, okay,
I have a couple attorneys who sit in my Discord and like and
basically contribute in terms of arguing about this stuff back
and forth. And I've heard that this could actually probably in
and of itself almost be reason to either grant the protective
order or go ahead and uh and keep the transcript sealed. So Desi's
been betting on this transcript getting unsealed so that he can
go and do content on it and make it seem like Pixie is a massive
liar to everybody, right? And I've heard that this is probably
going to be a significant piece if the judge does decide to keep
it sealed. This will probably be the biggest reason why is like
I think this guy's actually going to go be malicious with it.
Oh, 100%. Yeah. He's like, I'll show you harassing behavior.
And it's like, geez, man. Like this is this is he he he completely
shot himself in the foot doing that, you know? All he had to
do all he had to do was just let it just hang tight >> when
you uh Oh, go go go. Sorry. >> He just he couldn't he couldn't
just leave well enough alone for a little >> And uh >> yeah,
I just I just don't I don't know why he did it.
>> That seems to be the last like 10 different mistakes
he's made regarding these this like the Rose leaks, right? The
the the leaks from November 20. It's I don't know why he's doing
this. I don't know why he's doing that. I don't I can't track
like a a rational motive through a lot of these decisions. And
it's been like it it almost it's like somebody making all the
wrong moves in chess and it's like I know this isn't good for
you but now I'm just confused. I think like there's something
for a second you get like a little bit like is there some other
plan? But I don't think there is. I think the guy's just >> I
I think so. Oh, I think so. At this point, I mean, he's, you
know, it's I think he thought he might get a lot more cover than
he did on this, but uh I I think he misread the room on this
ultimately. Uh yeah, I I think he misread the room. I think he
was getting I The other thing is I think he gets um like he's
got a pretty cult-like following, right? And I think he gets
them on board and doesn't realize that like a lot of the other
people aren't necessarily on board with the way he talks about
this or approaches it. Um like to regular people, it just wouldn't
look the same. So he can get like his whole his whole group's
on board with him like reading that transcript and they all think
that's awesome and then it gets like put into a pleading and
it's like oh yeah you're probably here. >> Mhm. No, I agree.
I agree. >> With regards to um do you if you're the lawyer
on this are you happy that this guy is just like patting out
your billing or are you like kind of losing your mind that he's
like a completely unmanageable client? I mean, I'm he as long
as the checks are clearing, I'm not really too worried at the
end of the day. I mean, this is this is if if this turns into
a disaster, this isn't going to hurt him because, you know, he
he deals with the big dogs. This is just kind of like something
he can use to say later, look, I deal with streamers. >> Yeah,
sure. And I think um yeah, it doesn't hurt Bettler. I was just
thinking like it might be a headache that like you could easily
you could do a lot in this case. you could probably make this
case like kind of go away for him or you feel like that and then
you this guy's kind of he's cuz I think sorry I need to include
something first. I think when you hire Brettler I don't think
you hire Bretler for the best lawyer although he is a very good
lawyer. I think you hire Bretler for the PR approach right where
he understands that you got to mix PR with the like the actual
case that like a lot of lawyers would just tell you shut the
[__] up the whole time and I think he understands
I'm going to actually manage your PR and tell you how to speak
and like actually go after these people publicly without getting
in trouble.
I think that's why you hire Brettler. I don't know if you have
any different thoughts on that. I >> Well, Brer Brler has
that experience of like being able to navigate like he dealt
with like Harvey Weinstein and like that's about as bad as it
gets. So, yes, he's he's
he's got a lot of experience dealing with that. >> Yeah.
And so, like downstream of that, I think Breler might get concerned
that like Destiny is doing so much to up the P PR side of it,
which is I think something he markets to people that like, hey,
even if you kind of end up paying out in court, here's what happens
on the PR side after I represent you, right? like I help you
massage the narrative so that you can keep being like a public
figure and here's how this has worked out. I think Destiny's
done a lot to that side. And I wonder if that would um sort of
change how Brett thinks about running this case. I I mean it
can a little bit, but ultimately I think
I think for Bretter he sees it's going to turn into like a uh
you know this is probably going to settle at some point. Ultimately
it's just a matter of how far down he could drive uh how far
they can beat Pixie down on this. That's a that's a way to say
it. It seems like that is the approach is like we just want to
>> it's it's warfare. This is a this is a >> Yeah.
It's it's rough cuz one of the sides has, you know, millions
of dollars. The other side is just like kind of putting things
together on a shoestring budget. >> That that's a that's
a lot of time how this goes. It's a it's a war of who can withstand
the longest.
>> you like I'd like to sit here and tell you it's about
right or wrong, but that's usually not the case. >> No,
I I mean I understand that. >> Yeah. But it's it's just
it's the nature of it. >> I guess we will see if um I I
don't know if you've been keeping up on like the the drama side
of this, right, with with regards to like Ethan Klein, Hassan
Pike. Are you you entertain any of that stuff or you mostly keep
it to legal >> I mean, well, like I mean, Hassan has been
given mana from heaven at this >> You know, it's kind of
taken all the heat of off of all the Palestine stuff and all
of that. So, for now, yeah, Hassan's Hassan's eating good. You
know, keep pushing this. Keep pushing this. But eventually, Hassan's
an idiot. He's going to [__] this up and,
you know, be dealing with, you know, the fact he ballwashes every,
you know, terrorist he can come across. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Um, have you seen Destiny going after Ethan Klein recently? >> Yeah.
Yeah. That's I mean, Destiny's Destiny has no other option but
attack everybody he can. Cuz if he does that, he takes all the
oxygen out of the room cuz all he's doing is talking about all
that. The minute he gives dead air or lets up, you know, people
can
>> people start asking about that cam on his computer again.
Yeah.
>> That makes sense. Keep the conversation somewhere else.
I I do think of it as a lot of Right. >> Yeah. Well, somebody
says I'm a Hassan hater, boo. It's like Hassan can go out of
the helicopter.
>> We've uh Jesus, we love uh we love Pina references.
Okay. We love those. That's >> I'm just saying especially
Hassan. you tell me like you Hassan is a Hassan is an evil person.
>> We've got like a 50-50 split here of people who uh like
Hassan and then people who hate Hassan. The community was a lot
of people who hate Hassan, but then it's like uh kind of take
it to, you know, we cover a lot of Destiny's legal cases and
stuff and a lot of people who hate Destiny don't hate Hassan.
So, the community's kind of transitioned over time, but you're
welcome here with your uh hating of Hassan. Okay,
>> Hassan is rich and hot. I don't agree he's successful,
but yes, he's a good-looking man. >> You don't agree he's
successful? What? >> He's He's successful because of his
>> I think he's successful because of extraneous factors.
I think he's
I think he's uh successful on his own, too. But I I also think
that success is not like mainstream political success. It's like
uh being a mascot kind of. I would agree on that much for sure.
>> I I think that's fair. Yeah. Like he's Yes, he is doing
well. He owns his house in West Hollywood and all of that, but
um being any more than a jester is like, let's let's be real.
That's what we are. That's what we're doing here on the >> Yeah,
absolutely.
I'm I'm basically one step above a pan handler on the corner,
okay? And I don't pretend otherwise. Guys, sub, donate, sub,
donate, okay? This isn't This isn't a free show, all right? We're
trying to make a living here. >> Oh, just got a sub. Let's
go. Thank you. Yes, that's every day. We're here every day meet
the goals, okay? And
>> well, and I so and I agree. Hassan is successful at
that, but Hassan actually thinks he's leading the vanguard. Like
that's the difference. He doesn't he thinks he's actually all
about this and it's like no. >> I don't I don't know what
he thinks necessarily cuz like I I have a hard time deciding
whether or not he thinks he's leading the Vanguard or whether
he's quite aware that he is like kind of grifting and presenting
himself that way. I kind of go back and forth on those two things.
how aware he is of like what he does necessarily or what his
effect is. Anyway,
>> I I asked about all of that just for the uh sort of
to point that towards um I wouldn't be shocked if one of those
guys start getting um into funding Pixie's lawsuit, right? Since
that's some where they could put money to with Destiny. I think
Ethan Klein does that a lot. Ethan Klein's got a lot of money
and he's usually very happy to with people spend money to [__]
with people who are his enemies. Yeah, but he's got he's got
his hands full right now, burning down Froen and
uh Denims and Casey Tron like he he is he is hunting for scalps
and he is collecting intelligence information in this lawsuit.
That's all this is. It's a mole hunt and he is going to go after
everybody he can. I think he thinks at some point he will find
information that leads him to Hassan
out of this because that's that's what this lawsuit's about.
It's it's about making them suffer and it's about finding out
who's been screwing with him. >> Yeah. I totally agree
with you that it's not really about copyright at all. He just
wants to hurt the people who have been messing with him. >> Yeah.
But he he's he's in a very unique position that they were dumb
enough to actually break the law. >> Yeah. Um that and
do you think there's anything to the argument I don't know if
you've covered those those cases very much. Do you think there's
anything to the argument that um by reacting back and forth and
consistently letting them react back and forth and then doing
the preemptive uh registering of the content, do you think there's
any argument to the fact that he created the environment, he
basically sort of implicitly granted them a license?
I mean, they're going to make that argument, but at some point,
you know, he preemptively going out and registering it. Like
that's how normally you should be doing that as a like professional
creator of content. you should be registering things as you create
them. Like that's that's how the big boys do it.
So I I don't like I think they could try to argue that and I
think there's even comments from Ethan before where he's like
well yeah comment all the stuff and he's like say whatever you
got to say blah
maybe >> don't clip it out of context like >> yeah
what these guys are doing clearly where they clearly they state
this is what we're doing and then they disappear offcreen and
it's all about trying to screw with him that really hurts any
of the arguments they have. >> Yeah I think for Froggen
and and Caseyrons that's the case. I think Denims actually did
like a what would be by most people consider uh considered a
transformative react now. Is it really? I don't think so. Like
I don't think if she was doing that to the Lord of the Rings
she'd get a pass, right? But >> well that that that's the
thing. Like she let it run and then she talked about it afterwards.
Like ah
>> she paused quite considerably actually. I believe it's
a I forget if it's a two and a half hour video. She she I believe
slightly more than doubled the run time pausing during right
which isn't a perfect comparison. and she did do the whole thing
in full. I think it's almost certainly not fair use, but I would
say that a lot of people do run other people's content in full
and and comment and that's like sort of colloquially accepted
colloquially accepted as fair >> Well, and I mean I do
that like I'll watch a trial and I'll comment on it as it goes,
but it's you know like it depends on how you're doing it and
what you're doing it about. But for her,
you know, when she's like, "You're watching it here so you don't
have to watch like some of the ways that stuff was put together
and you know, the fact that she uh willingly let Ethan go out
and submit those subpoenas to Reddit.
I think she knows that they were all talking together and they
established their intent to screw with copyright. I think that's
the problem for at the end of the day. >> Yeah. So, would
Denims be could Denims be held liable for the Reddit's actions
if she has no direct communication with the subreddit? >> I
it would all depends on like I I think she does though.
>> Sure. But it would have to come down to like DMs, like
actual explicit like they go to Discovery, they search for that,
and if they don't find it, then uh
>> Yeah. I think that that'll hurt a lot. But I mean, once
again, Denims, Casey, Tron, and Froggen are not the smartest
people in the world. like did they properly cover their tracks
or did these mods make comments? Like I'm assuming Ethan has
already obtained a lot of things and he's holding on to them
till it comes time for discovery.
>> Oh, you think he's got a good idea that they were like
somebody told him or showed him proof that they were >> Yeah,
I I could I I could easily see these idiots sitting on a Discord
somewhere or in some sort of chat room talking about all this.
>> Yeah, I could see that. I could definitely see that.
Um Yeah. And he could also just be shaking the trees and trying
to scare everybody, too. I don't I I mean that that also possible.
>> I I think he I think a lot of this is just like ego.
He has the money to go and sue these people. I think a lot of
it I think I could see him doing it just to shake trees. But
I think ultimately unfortunately maybe Denims has some out, but
for Casey Trron and Froen, they kind of just with him in a way
that like it's I'm sorry. Uh this is another strict liability
crime, right? Like uh copyright infringement. I think it's another
strict liability crime. It's like it's going to come down to
it's not about their intent.
>> It's like it's going to come down to whether or not
you created a market replacement and whether or not um you transformed
it. And for at least Frogan and Caseyron, I don't see real any
real argument that they transformed it at all. So, I think they're
going to get hit with those statutory penalties from uh from
registering with the pre-registering it with the Library of Congress.
Right. You're familiar with that, right? How the the penalties
go up for them. Yeah. Yeah. >> Oh, yeah. Well, that's how
you that's how you get your statutories is that's the easiest
way to do it, >> which is uh pretty rough. Isn't it just
to deter Hassan Orbiter's chat message? Isn't it just to deter
Hassan orbiters to be anti Ethan? That's what I assumed. Well,
it's another effect, right, is reacting to his content probably
seems quite scary for these people now. I would imagine >> he
I I don't think he's necessarily afraid of them, but he wants
to uh like he I think he's willing to accept proper commentary,
but these people,
you know, really tried to snake him and I'm sure, you know, they
were on screen with Idubbbz doing the stupid little crap like
he's going after the people. He's going, like I said, he wants
to collect scalps and these are the scalps he wants. So, I mean
it, you know, like if Hassan had reacted to it, that would have
been okay because it was clearly I think, you know, Ethan would
have to say, "Yeah, he wanted Hassan to react to it." But for
these, yeah, he just wants to uh, you know, he thinks he's been
wronged. He thinks he's been wronged. He thinks these people
snaked him. You know, did they? I don't really think so. I mean,
but this is what you know, he feels that he's been agrieved and
he's seeking, you know, he's seeking satisfaction out of this.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um, if I could wrap it back to the Destiny
stuff, I've got just a couple more questions for you and then
if you um I'm I'm definitely not kicking you up, but if you wanted
to um you know, get on with your night, I would understand. I
really appreciate you coming on out of nowhere. Like um I had
you asked those questions and >> Okay. All right. Um,
so big question that I've gotten a couple people DM me to ask
is if that group chat exists and if we take that email that was
sent uh that the Kiwi Farms user, you know, produced. If we take
that as fact and say, okay, there were actual depictions of CSAM
put into that conversation, what culpability is there for the
people participating in that conversation? >> You know,
it's it all depends like that's going to be very fact specific,
but some of them could be in trouble for receiving it. Depends
what like did they touch it? Did they look at it? You know what
what happened with it? >> Yeah. Okay. >> I mean like
one of the that like the like one of the only guaranteed ways
of showing you had nothing to do with it is you see that you're
like wait she's 17. Yeah. Leave the conversation. Like there
there's it there's nothing.
It's nothing good for those people. You're probably getting raided
if you're in that group >> Yeah. I mean if there Yeah.
I I would think they have to right. Like >> like ultimately
They're going to You got a call from the police saying, "Hey,
come on down here. We got some questions for you." >> It's
rough. I I don't know. I think given that given that like now
they all know that that's happened. I got to imagine there's
a lot of people who are sweating and thinking like if I can get
all of these logs taken somewhere right now, um that would be
best. Like if I can get to the cops and say, "Here's all the
logs. I had no idea what was going on." Or, you know, I was assured
this person wasn't under 18. You know, I I didn't know what's
going on. Here's every I assume there's people I'd assume that
that phone for the cyber crimes division ringing off the hook
right now. >> Anybody in that group chat better be talking
to a lawyer like yesterday. >> Oh boy. Yeah. I That's uh
that's not good. >> That you better hope your dog's wearing
a bulletproof vest.
>> Jesus. Send the dog away. Okay. For a couple weeks.
>> That too. That's another way. >> Yeah. Yeah. You're
not a fan of cops, I'm guessing.
>> Well, I'm not a fan of the cops. No. But I mean they
do. They shoot dogs. That's what they do. >> Hey, I've
heard this. I've heard people talk about this or many people
are saying this, man. All right. And then the other question
was basically, what do you think the road looks like for Pixie
financially? I think she's been stuck at $50,000 for a while
given how many motions have been written. Like, what do you think's
going on there? I know Destiny keeps saying that people are working
proono for her. I haven't seen any like evidence of that, but
also I don't know, maybe they maybe they would decide to after
a certain point, like, hey, we feel like this person's a total.
Certainly seems like Desi paid off one of her lawyers, right?
>> It's not pro bono. It's they'd be working on contingency
at that point, meaning we'll take a cut of whatever you make.
But yeah, I could easily see that, but that's not something that
would have to get disclosed on the record. So, whatever you and
your client have worked out, that's nobody else's business. >> Yeah.
So, I I would say probably Destiny saying that there's no reason
to believe that he would have any knowledge of that, right?
>> He's saying that to
>> I think it's fair. I'm sure they burned through most
of the money,
if not all of it already, easily.
>> Yeah. So, like another year and a half, two years to
go to trial, like it seems probable that she's going to burn
through a lot of that money and they'll have to decide whether
or not whether or not it's worth working on contingency, >> If
it if it's not gone by, like if I'm I'd be surprised if there's
any left by
>> No, a lawsuit is you Here's how a lawsuit works. You
shove all your money into a pile on a table and you light it
on fire. Maybe you get all of it back.
maybe you get a dollar back saying, "You know what? Yeah, that
guy was wrong, but you're only getting a dollar back." Maybe
you get none of it back. And a lot of times, people don't get
any of it >> Yeah. Jeez. Uh, so >> that's what happens.
That's what
>> In your experience, when lawyers start working on contingencies,
the the
quality of the work, I would imagine, has to go down, right?
They're going to spend less time on that case. >> No, cuz
I'm I'm hunting for a whale, man. And I want to I want to win
now.
Like it it's there's an incentive for me to make sure I keep
the quality up because I want to win. Like Destiny has money.
I want a piece of his ass.
Do you think the probability of higher damages for things like
emotional distress goes up given Destiny's, you know, joking
about Pixie herself on social media talking about how she's a
totally like she's like a total gold digging horn in his chat.
like with the with the way he talks about her. Does that affect
how a judge might, you know, render their judgment at the very
end of >> Yeah. Well, I mean, it's not necessary the judge,
but a jury. I mean, he you're you're going to have to go in front
of a jury full of normies and explain why, hey, me acting like
this wasn't that big a deal,
you know? And that that's that's where it's going to be tough
for uh Destiny cuz it's not going to be a bunch of DGers. It's
not going to be, you know, Twitch watchers >> even Yeah.
internet commentators either. >> Yeah, it's going to be
regular people from his community and they are not going to be
thrilled with this.
>> You would think that's the that's the one another thing
though with Miami. I'm never sure how that's going to work. Um
cuz it is conservative, right? Sorry, Florida in general is conservative.
Miami, you know, bit more retirees, older skew older, but also
like in terms of Destiny, like if I'm Pixie's lawyers, I I want
to make sure the jury knows about this guy's comments on the
firefighter, his comments about kids, right? Uh now these allegations,
the CESAM allegations, I feel like you got to work all of those
things in there to kind of tilt the way the jury looks at >> They're
going to try. They're going to try, but there's going to be,
you know, that's all that can be all limited through the through
the rules of evidence that, you know, what's relevant? What makes
it more likely or less likely that this actually occurred? You
know, is it relevant to proving the case? So, some of these things
might get in, but a lot of it probably won't. >> I would
imagine they'll try to keep as much of it out as possible. >> Yeah.
Well, I I just think a lot of it probably wouldn't get in. If
I was the judge, I probably wouldn't let a lot of it in. Now,
Destiny's history of doing all this with nudes and sharing nudes
and all that. That could be used because that shows clearly,
you know, you shouldn't do that and he has a history of doing
it. It's not like his first time ever that he did this.
>> Um, it's not. He actually has a video where he has to
explain that his ex-wife Molina had to chastise him for sending
her tapes with him to other people without her consent. Like
that is on the
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And there's also
>> and some of the other orbiters he's had this scandal
before where like he sent my nudes out and everybody's like,
"Ah, that's just even." Uh, he had this happen in I want to say
with someone named I think it was Blue Tea where he had sent
her nudes to a group chat and and she ended up leaking his pics
on his Twitter.
>> Uh in response to finding out that they were making
not so nice comments. He's got a couple different um allegations
in this like ballpark on our >> He's also just overall
being a suggest. It's like you know at some point
you know better. >> Yeah. And like realistically just the
overall physio, you know, he looks like he owns a panel van is
I I feel like that's gonna work against him. I don't know how
you feel about that, but personally he people Well, I mean he
the I will say this much. The video of him when he came back
from court that day wearing a suit. Everybody cleans up pretty
good. I mean to be fair though, we all could be easily look like
we own panel vans. Really when it comes down to
>> Uh I don't even show my face, man. I I heard you. You
talk [__] you talk. I heard you on your stream. Somebody
linked me a clip. I hate this guy because he doesn't show his
face. When I face reveal, I'll make sure I send you a message.
Okay. I'll send you a message so we can >> just like, you
know, I guess for me it's like I show my face, so I'm never really
worried about it. >> Yeah. Yeah. >> But um I will
say one of your people in your chat and I did did pull them up
to make sure it's correct. Yes. In Florida there is a must, not
a may obligation to report. So yes, he is correct. I misstated
that. >> Um in Florida they have to report. Um many states
though you don't have to >> would that that's the the lawyer
obligation like the the lawyer >> obligation obligation
to report criminal activity. So yes I
I will I was trying to pull that out. >> Okay. All right.
Yeah that's Oh that's cool. I'm glad that you um I I feel like
a lot of people don't do that. They don't say oh I was wrong
over here. It's a very difficult thing for a lot of people. Oh
man. All right. Well I can't think of any more questions. I don't
know if you have questions for me about any of this stuff or
any of the stuff that's gone on. Um, if you ever do or you ever
want to do, you know, any content on this stuff, you ever want
somebody who knows a lot of the the stuff going on, feel free
to shoot me a >> Yeah, I definitely will. >> Um,
I've got your your link pinned in the chat if you want to shout
out your >> Yeah, sure. You guys can find me at Potentially
Criminal on YouTube. uh got, you know, obviously the Destiny
stuff, the Ethan Klein stuff, all